hey dudes chicks friends people who hit
me where I live have a bit of an update
video for you guys I know usually update
videos suck ass you like seeing my
content you're like sweet movie review
movie movie trailer movie game awesome
but I want to keep you guys updated as
to what to look forward to on my channel
so we'll make this fun as fun as an
update video can be make it awesome so
the weekend of Friday August 31st
through Sunday September 2nd I will be
at PAX Prime in Seattle why cuz I live
near Seattle and I'm cheap and I don't
want to fly anywhere but I will drive
there and what is PAX Prime it's a big
video game convention I've covered it
the last couple years this will be the
third year and it's awesome I get to
play games that aren't out yet it's like
you think of III to Seattle I'm bringing
my thoughts on the games that I play
there that aren't even out yet I'm not
gonna lie when you're at a convention
you get to play games that aren't out
yet so it's just not a bad weekend
there's no way shape or form that that
is a shitty weekend like what are the
main requests that I get it's like oh do
can you talk about the new naughty dog
game coming out The Last of Us I would
love to but I figured I might play that
PAX Prime so hopefully I can give you a
hands-on review that would be awesome
right that's rhetorical it would
actually be awesome this is for my video
game subscribers who are like dude do
you review games anymore I do just games
take a while to beat there's really been
nothing out that I'm like oh yeah I want
to drop 60 bucks on that right now
busy man a lot of time I do still play
games hopefully this fall this fall has
a lot of cool stuff coming out so you'll
see more game content there for sure but
PAX Prime will whet the appetite so
ladies and gentlemen I'm feeling the
Sony booth is completely gonna kill it
it's gonna be awesome hopefully this
year they have the Wii U they didn't
have it last year but you know the Wii U
comes out a couple months after PAX
Prime there's no reason not to have it
Nintendo if you're listening you're not
but I'm just saying but yeah last year I
met a lot of fans at PAX it was badass
so if you see me at PAX dude say hi if
you want to know where I am at PAX Prime
follow me on twitter at jeremy John's
three symbols my name is easy this year
like last year I'll be like oh hey I'm
at this booth oh hey I'm at this booth
kept people up to speed the fans I've
met thus far have been awesome so hey if
you see me at PAX Prime say hi can't
wait to meet you and this Wednesday
hopefully it's this Wednesday by the
time you see this video it's Wednesday
the what Wednesday is it how about a
touch of my day twenty second Wednesday
the 22nd that's pathetic I don't know
what Wednesday is Wednesday the 22nd I
will be down in LA on the schmoes no
podcast at 9:00 a.m. Pacific time that's
California la time for those of you who
don't know will be there live on tow top
Network I'll put a link below for toda
it'll actually be in the studio I'll be
there the entire time will be top
and it'll be awesome so be sure to check
that out if you see this video after
that I'll put the link below where you
can catch up it won't be live but it'll
still be there so Wednesday August 22nd
I will be in the studio on the schmoes
know podcast it'll be awesome then the
weekend of August 31st through September
2nd I will be at PAX Prime in Seattle
that is what I call a party my friends
that's what we do on my channel it's not
just me talking to videos no we're here
for the party and I will try my best to
bring it to you however as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more